all machine learning Engineers aspire to
attain precise predictions through their
algorithms these learning algorithms can
be broadly categorized into supervised
and unsupervised K means clustering
falls into the unsupervised category
wherein the input data lacks labeled
responses so hello everyone my name is
mang and welcome to this fantastic video
on K means clustering algorithm in this
video we will delve into K means
clustering algorithm topics like what is
K means type of clustering in machine
learning advantages and disadvantages of
K means clustering and application of K
means algorithm at the end of this video
we will Implement handson using the K
means algorithm so just a quick info for
you K means is after all an algorithm
that is based on AI and machine learning
a professional who wants to switch
careers with AIML by learning from the
experts then try giving simply lar
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning from PD University in
collaboration with IB
this AIML course was delivered in
collaboration with P universities and
IBM learn in demand skills such as
machine learning deep learning NLP
computer vision reinforcement learning
generative AI prompt engineering chat
gbt and many more so hurry up androll
now the link is in the pin comment and
the description box below so without any
further Ado let's get started so what is
a means clustering algorithm so K means
clustering is stand out as a
unsupervised learning algorithm devoid
of labeled data
unlike its supervised counterparts its
primary function involves partitioning
objects into cluster that exhibit
similarities within but differ from
object in other cluster the variable K
in the K means denotes a numerical value
indicating desired number of cluster to
be formed for instance setting K cler to
impl the creation of two distinct
cluster determining the optimal value
for K in a given data set is a crucial
task so to illustrate the concept of K
means consider consider a cricket
scenario imagine having data on a
numerous cricket players worldwide
detailing their runs and wickets in the
last 10 matches the object is to
categorize the players into two clusters
batsmen and Bowers exemplifying the
application of K means in a grouping
similar data so moving forward let's
discuss types of clusters so clustering
is a type of unsupervised learning
wherein data points are grouped into
different sets based on their degree of
similarity so the various types of
clustering are hierarchical clustering
ing partitioning clustering soical
clustering is further divided into
agglomerative clustering divisive
clustering so partitioning clustering is
further subdivided into K means
clustering and fuzzy c means clustering
so moving forward let's discuss some
advantages of K means cluster so number
one is simple and easy to implement so
the K means algorithm is easy to
understand and Implement making it a
popular choice of clustering for the
task the second one is fast and
efficient K means is computationally
efficient and can handle large data set
with high
dimensionality the third one is
scalability K means can handle large
data set with a large number of data
points and can be easily scaled to
handle even larger data sets the fourth
one is flexibility K means can be easily
adapted to different application and can
be used with different distance metrics
and initialization methods so now moving
forward let's discuss some disadvantage
of key means the number one is
sensitivity to initial centroids K means
are sensitive to the initial selection
of centroids and can converge to a
suboptimal solution the second one is
requires specifying number of clusters
the number of clusters K needs to be
specified before running the algorithm
which can be challenging in some
application the third one is sensitive
to outliers K means is a sensitive to
outliers which can have a significant
impact on the resulting cluster moving
forward let's discuss some application
of K means clustering K means clustering
is used used in a variety of examples of
business cases in real life like
academic Performance Based on this
course students are categorized into
grades like a b or c grade the second
one is diagnostic system the medical
profession uses K means in creating
smarter medical decision support system
especially in the treatment of lever
alignment the third one is search
engines clustering forms a backbone of
search engine when a search is performed
the search result need to be grouped and
the search engines very often uses
clustering to do this so the number
fourth is wireless sensor networks the
clustering algorithm plays the role of
finding the cluster heads which collect
all the data in their respective cluster
so now let's move on to the demo part so
hello guys welcome to this demo part of
K means clustering algorithm so this is
our jupyter kernel so first I will
rename it so we will do some Iris flower
classification using and we will make
some clusters okay using K means
clustering algorithm so here I will
write K
means
cluster okay
yes so first we will import some major
libraries right okay first we will
import some major libraries
like
import pandas as PD then
import
numi as
NP then import M plot
lip do p
plot as PLT I hope everyone knows
because these are some basic libraries
of machine learning or you can say
python okay this mat plot is used for
the plotting of
graphs then we will import
cbor as
SNS then from
eSalon dot
cluster
import
import K
means then from
esar do
Matrix
import s
house okay
score then
from SK Lear dot
preprocessing import min max
scale okay let me run it okay everything
is working fine or still loading right
so these are some major like okay there
is one okay there is an spelling
mistake yeah so now we will read the
data set so you can find the data set
link from the description box
below Iris equals to PD do read
CSV
then iris. CS
right then
x equals to Iris do
iog and colum
comma 0 comma 1 comma 2 comma 3 dot
values dot
values
okay so moving forward we will see some
basic function of python like info or
shape like describe so I will write
iris. info why Iris because I gave here
my data frame name is Iris
right okay and I need Iris
of 0 to 10 range okay so as you can see
this is my data set this is ID SE land
that se width petal length petal width
and
species
okay so moving forward we will what we
will do we will set the frequency
distribution of the particular
species so first let me give some spaces
for better
visual so here I will write
Iris underscore
outcome equals to PD dot cross
tab
then index equals to
Iris and
species
comma columns equals
to
count right here I will write Iris
uncore
outcome okay so here we will making the
make the cross step and we are naming
the count column
okay so as you can see the spaces Iris
SATA is 50 and iris versy color is 50
and Iris vgin is 50 okay so these are
some count of particular species okay
this
species
right so moving forward we will set the
distribution so I will write
Iris
SATA equals to
Iris DOT
log
and
species equals
to I
set
right okay here I will write I
right okay so we will do this for Iris
virgin color and iris versy color and
virginic also right so what I will do I
will just copy
it and paste it here for two times then
I will change here
this wory
color and virgin
right and here I will
change the
name Mery color
and
virgin
right okay
cool everything seems good
I is color and R is spelling is
right
okay so moving forward we will plot some
graph
right and we will see the particular
density of the padal length and padal
width okay so what I will write here I
will write here this SNS
dot
facet
GD
Iris comma Q equals to
species okay comma size =
3 comma do
map then
SNS dot distinct
plot
comma I need first
P okay what I can do I can copy here
from ble
length and P it there why I'm doing
because of some spelling mistakes
okay then dot
addore
Lor
Legend right so this we will do for the
padal width and the saple
length so what I can
[Music]
do I can just copy it okay so I can just
copy
it and paste it here for the two times
then pedal width I
need
change
here and then I need saple
length
Okay Okay
some error is
there
right okay what did is say saying name
of index battle WID SL
the
call
width
spes yeah you can ignore this warnings
right so this is the density of petal
length and the particular three species
uh setosa Versa vinica because we have
only three species in particular you
know data set right this is the sample
length of the density got it so moving
forward what we will do we will make a
box plot of the patter length so I will
write SNS
dot box
plot xals to
species comma
y equals
to P length
okay CM this is the right name comma
data equals to
Iris then PLT do
show okay box plot it is PL T yeah so as
you can see the pattern length of the
particular species this is uh Iris SATA
is between 1 and two then versic is is
between 3.5 to somewhere 5.3 or 5.2 as
you can see
right so moving forward we will make uh
you know different kind of plot which is
known as the violent plot v i o l i n
violent plot
so here I type SNS do violin
F
plot
then xals to
species comma y
to
pattern length
CM okay comma data equals to
Iris right then PLT do
show
okay some error is
there met length spelling is
wrong yeah so this is some
viin plot as you can see here the shape
are of viin right
okay so moving forward uh we will do one
major plot we will make some major plot
known as the scatter plot right so for
that I will write here SNS do
set
style wi
grid right and SNS
dot pairplot
Iris comma h
species comma size
three and PLT do
show you can ignore always you can
ignore These
Warnings okay see as you can see here
the particular scatter plot for the
saple length in this you know this blue
color resembles the setosa and this
orange color is VY color and this green
color is Irish
vgin right this is for all the full
graph this saple length saple width
petal L and petal
right
okay so moving forward what we will
do so
here K means so K means is a centroid
based algorithm or a distance based
algorithm where we can calculate the
distance to assign a point to a cluster
right so in K means each cluster is
associated with a centroid okay so how
to implement K means clustering right so
first choose the number of clusters K
you know small small clusters or select
the K random points from the data as
centroids and assign all the points to
the closest cluster of the croid right
and then recompute the Androids of newly
formed clusters then you can repeat the
steps three and four okay so here what
we will do first we will find the
optimum number of clusters for K means
classification first we will do
that okay so here I will write from
Escalon do cluster
import
K and W CSS just giving as blank
are okay for I in
range 1 to
11 right so K
means equals
to gam means then n
clusters equals to I
comma in it
equals
to K
means right then Max iteration would
be
300 comma n
nyren 10 and
random
State Z
got it then K
means do
fit
X right and
wcss do
append ging
dot
inertia gameing is
not okay
it's small
K and it should be either K means is
random
for
it what I will
do
yes so now moving forward but uh using
the elbow method so you what is elbow
method right it's a base graph okay
elbow graph elbow shape graph you can
say so using the elbow method uh to
determine the optimal number of cluster
for the K means clustering so we will
create here so we will create here one
albow method graph right so for that I
will add PLT do
plot
range one comma
11 comma
wcss and PLT do
title
the
elbow
method PLT do X
LEL
number of
clusters then I will
write PLT do y
label
CSS
vt. I think you guys are confused what
is wcss right so wcss means within
clusters sum of squares okay I run it
so as you can see this is the elbow
shape graph right so these are the
number of clusters okay this is uh
within cluster sum of squares this is
right
5,000 this this this this
okay so moving forward what we will do
we will implement the K meain clustering
right now okay so I will give some
space yeah so I will write K means
equals to K
means
ncore
clusters = to 3 comma init =
to K
means right okay I can copy it
from
got
it then
ycore K
means to K means dot
fit and
predict
X
okay so here what we will do we will
visualize the cluster so I will write
PLT do
scatter
X Yore K
means
2+
0aa
X
Yore k
mean
to 0a
1 then and I will
give
s equals to se to 100 then
C equals to it should be
purple right and
label I is
sat
okay so I will copy this for the other
virgin and ver color
right and I will change here to
orange
and
green then here I will write
Vira then here I'll write
veric okay
okay so what I will do I will change
here then 2 comma
okay and here one here
two right yes so as you can see we have
scattered particular cluster of between
the species right the iris satsa is this
purple okay this purple one is Iris
satsa and this versy color is the orange
okay and the uh this vinica is a green
right so how we did we use
this right this sample length sample
width and patter l p width and according
to that we just made the cluster of
using K's cluster so now what we will do
we we will uh plot the cids of the
cluster okay and I will write here
only PLT do
scatter K means dot
cluster
centers g
means
cluster centers
right column
one comma
1 comma s = to 100 and
Cal
R what will happen we will find the
centroids okay particular Cent so I will
write here r
then
label equals to
centroid
centroid Okay C let's
put then PLT dot
Legend So as you can see these are some
centroids of the particular
graph
okay right so moving forward we will
make our last scatter plot of 3D scatter
plot okay for the Androids to check the
Androids
figure PLT
dot
figure it's same like above so what I
will do I will copy
it and paste it here
okay so now we will do for the
centroids it's
same and I will copy it here I copy it
two
times so as you can see this is our 3D
plot for to check or to find the
centroids right so these red colors are
the
centroids okay see I have set the red
color
centroid particular centroid
okay so yes so this is how you can do or
implement the K means clustering to find
the centroid okay so with this said we
have come to end of this video if you
have any query regarding any of the
topic in this video please do let us
know in the comment section below our
team of expert will help you as soon as
possible do like share and subscribe do
like share and subscribe to stay updated
from Simply learn Channel thank you and
keep learning with simply staying ahead
in your career requires continuous
learning and upscaling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domain
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here